all right we're going to start now in
Charlotte yeah
[Music]
all right
good evening to you all come please
our subject for today is
our subject for today is which is the
prayer
and the meaning of the prayer
linguistically speaking is Dua
which means to supplicate I eat raising
one's hands and supplicating invoking
their lord
uh uh as Allah says
not really their prayers
or invocations or reassurance for them
foreign
take all profit from their wealth and
charity
by which you purify them and call them
increase
and invoke Allah's blessings upon them
yeah
really
or do I your supplications or
reassurance for them so that's the
linguistic meaning of prayer Salah okay
so we're going to read
I'm going to read the subject
you guys are going to be listening yeah
Allah
are you ready
you got the page you got the app in
front of you
all right
there's some Hefty words here but don't
worry
the teacher said
foreign
from the five pillars of Islam
the second pillar
is from the five pillars of Islam
arcan is the plural of rukun rukun means
well done
also has another meaning in the Arabic
language which is zawia which is the
corner
that's Hokum yeah
Slim
foreign foreign
and
[Music]
the prayer is mandatory upon every
Muslim
means
pubescent of age grown up by League
basically means he's of age now
foreign
of age to understand between
basically good and bad
some of the self this is an Affairs I
believe how do they know whether the
ways of age
Somerset up until he's able to tell the
Beautiful World from the ugly woman yeah
yeah
between good looking and bad looking
uh
uh so tajibu comes from the word
yeah
obviously it's tejibu here because it's
going back to the Salah and Salah is so
that's why it's got time instead of yeah
okay
foreign
it's impermissible to delay it from its
correct time I.E the prayer
Allah
verily the prayer for the Believers is
at an appointed time
foreign
and it's permissible for the one
traveling
and the one who is sick
to delay
is
and also to delay Maghrib with Aisha
with the intention of
combining Nia in Arabic language means
everyone says
cost means intent
for example Sharia
is in regards to the intents of the
the five intents or the things in which
the Sharia comes to protect here so you
might see that in another possible
lesson
for the one travelingham
if you were to the you know travel to
Belgrade because yeah
all right next fakara
is
if the Muslim enters upon the prayer
it's despised for him
despise that he looks to thee right
and to the left meaning to turn from
right
to left
yeah
foreign
there's no tie
even though it's written it should be
high
well
and it's also disliked
despised to snap
or crack or pop his
alphabet what's up
fingers
what
and to raise his vision towards the
skies
foreign
ah it's despised that he places his
hands upon his waist khasira the middle
part
that comes from the word meaning waste
yeah
oh sorry
rather he places his right hand
foreign
let me just check the camera because
it's a bit warm sometimes the camera it
turns itself off when it gets too hot
now we're good
is everything understood
okay
almost there
and it's despised for him
little bowly
so it's despised to him to be one that
is carrying with him I on his clothes
Bowl
which is urine which is feces or
excrement or stool yeah
it is like thesis excretment you know
what comes out from behind yeah
yeah that which comes out from the you
know behind
okay so today's lesson alhamdul is
actually very important uh listen I'm
not going to give you everything in here
uh
is understood
how this means one that is confined for
example from Hamas to be confined or
some people says like prison as well
yeah
so ha this means one that is confined
you know with little bowl
carrying urine and I'll save us from
that because obviously the person was
punishing the Cobra for this he didn't
used to purify himself from uh
you're in okay
uh uh follow as I mentioned
what's the meaning of prayer
linguistically
you say
in terms of what's the meaning of the
prayer in regards to the legislation of
Allah
everyone say this together
foreign
worship which contains
sayings
and actions
[Music]
included
it is opened up I.E The Prayer by way of
saying Allahu Akbar
that is the definition of
so if you write that down try to
memorize it for next week it's a good
time yeah next week might take the
salahada
all right next page people yeah
obviously I'm diving into Islamic
Studies slightly
and it's
this is uh beneficial all right ajip
also the following questions
of the complete responses all right
read this together now because some of
the writing's a bit confusing
yeah it might look like tejido but I
believe it should be
so what's in your book Hassan foreign
the prayer is a literature upon every
Muslim who's of age and sane
the prayer is obligatory upon every
Muslim who is of age and Saint
well done
what is the traveler allowed to do
together
from it's allowed it's permitted for the
most
and also the sick person
foreign
yeah
sorry
sometimes I have a problem with Arabic
I've got mistakes as well I would say I
want to score
I would cut it I would say mahil
um
so you give yourself time to like cut
into over here because sometimes he or
who will help
so what are the
despised actions
done during
whilst
yeah for example
meanwhile yeah means what people
meanwhile it's also in book one this
yeah after that
yeah
meanwhile there's a lot of words today
don't worry inshallah all of this will
come back to haunt you or if I said to
you
mean time
the boy
meanwhile
my dad was surveillance in me
foreign
and my dad hit me
so once you start understanding these
sentences you can start making sentences
you can start making sentences
during talking
what do you mean give me a sentence like
we were talking or we were working
whilst he was talking
now
uh
it depends on the Sarah depends on the
context right yeah we can give a few
examples of that yeah
what are the despised actions that one
uh should not really do whilst in the
prayer now go back to the Hayward you
haven't memorized this I know it's too
long go back to the Hayward type
go for it
and
was
the spice that he yells he turns to thee
yeah
he turns to the right and left in
what's up
and that he snaps or pops his
his fingers
next one
this one's Haram this one you should not
do
yes when you look to thee
yeah
and that he raises his sight or Vision
towards he
Skye next one
yes
yeah you'll be snatched your eyesight
will be snatched
and I'll say what's in that I mean all
right oh yeah
said it together
and it's the spice that he places his
hand upon his
waist waste well done yeah let me just
check if this is still recording because
it's getting rather warm in there
excellent
all right lastly
all right come on you say slowly
little bowling
Allah
so it's despised that he'd be one that
is confined or carrying
urine little bowl owl raw it raw it is
excretion excrement stool yeah
no he can't like be carrying that
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
he should go toilet before yeah
that's probably better to use as a
translation so you shouldn't be one
that's in need of you know going toilet
or you know in relieving himself the
Arabs say India when they say Indiana
I don't need they don't say literally I
want to go take a uh you know thingy
magic to say and the hajja they express
it very lightly they don't say uh
the word it as explicit as it comes yeah
it means need but when you saying
does I understand yeah
a lot of languages I believe it must be
like that but Arabic was the first
language I realized is like that all
right
foreign
what does that mean
the synonymous
synonymous synonymous words words are
close in meaning to it
yeah you know when you get thesaurus you
know thesaurus yeah it brings D
synonymous words to it the synonymous
words close in meaning
now
well done yes
means permitted another meaning is
I permitted you
smackly some people say give me
permission yes so the one is yes
it's right below you see yeah
foreign
yeah
which means to turn
around
all right read this together your
Hardware
so he basically moves his rats
your meaning
right and Lefty
is looking towards the place of
frustration
he raises his vision Towards the Sky
which one is
foreign
all right next one
which is
waste is it
is it Jim no is it gem
gen
I mean he's like this the middle or the
fight yeah so it's jumbo yeah
all right lastly
Kelly Martin
[Music]
insert every word from that which comes
all right so now basically this is where
Arabic
takes place in reality
is giving you a verb which is
present tense
actional verb he wants you to put that
in age room normal feeder who reckons
they can do it
all of the responses are available in
the
what does that mean first and foremost
in a sentence
notes
you don't have to do it from the top of
your head that's not my condition it's
just getting used to using the Arabic
language so you could say yeah
means it's despised all right next one
Muhammad you want to give it a go
all right no worries
Nabil
a
um
foreign
so if you were you know traveling you
it's permissible for you to combine
between yeah
what does that mean
s
and
Muslim
s
upon every Muslim it's mandatory too
really and truly in a lesson they'll
make you write this
literally they'll make you right on job
but because we're doing it here and it's
not exactly the best oh you know setting
in terms of getting things done but I'm
just telling you guys this is why we're
saying it out loud but writing is also
part of it so what's going to happen now
I'm gonna tell you straighten them
your listening skills and understanding
skills were going to shoot off in
comparison to your writing skills now
if you do this for the whole of this
very book you're listening
ah
your skills which is listening
and understanding
huh I'm gonna Excel
Excel but your writing won't necessarily
be too good
yeah that's why writing is important if
you don't write now
you will excel in the two but it doesn't
mean you're at loss
you're not from the losers Insha'Allah
but you're still gaining yeah be soon
yeah be soon to be confined or holding
yeah
so put that in a sentence
should I just give it easy one yeah
they can find them from the food
foreign
lesson but the reality is this is how it
comes in Arabic there will be Hefty
lessons now and again
does anyone play football
like professionally you are for school
don't play football
play football yeah
sometimes you get hard games
so you get hard games like it's raining
you know the terrain's not exactly too
good you keep the ball it goes like
super fast because it's raining on the
grass it's a hard game it's not Arabic
you get hard lessons now and again but
that's the reality obviously these hard
lessons you know bring out the real men
you know and obviously we're all real
men in sha Allah but the reality is you
need hard lessons now and again so
obviously you know any
give you a more in-depth understanding
of what the language is like it's not
all the time but it does happen
uh okay next one next page we're almost
done
which means
what does that mean
s
he's placing
this place in the book in front of thee
teacher he plays past tense
he's placing halian like he's doing that
right now
so what type of sentence could we use
Hassan
foreign
what does that mean
he places right hand
yeah right hand
well done he placed his
above his so he placed his right hand
over his left hand
above his Southern
or done
winner
so you know obviously bring forth the
words together in order to
create
beneficial sentences and Salah
what do you want from that how do you
reckon you could do that go on speak
forth
let me just see if it's still equipped
in
ah
so well done so the easy way to do this
yeah is just to start the sentence with
the fitting do you remember I said that
last lesson
I said to you this last week so you say
yeah
it's impermissible it's prohibited to
delay the prayer
from its correct time
all right
what's this one going to be now
well done
the one praying
and to snap pop crack his fingers
what's that one gonna be it's the
hardest one
you have to have the book for certain
things
come on
remember to start the sentence with the
field what do you think it is so you've
got yajibu
yeah wow
it's not used to happen
I'll give it to you in the corner so
what I have yeah
alumni
Allah
it's manjuji within the prayer to place
the
right hand
over the left hand yes
foreign
yeah
but yeah that's how that lesson goes
on
you guys done well with such short
time